Mike McCarty hey you have played the new
far cry again yeah I'm excited because
far cry is a fun video game series and
I'm excited to hear about the latest Far
Cry game I haven't played a far cry
again none of us have since october of
2014 well then a new one I guess with
that pagan man and all that stuff and
the helicopters and great great fun yeah
all around great fun right elephants and
right elephants yeah who need why you
need anymore cut it off their feature
list white elephant go home white
elephant simulator done at New Farquhar
game dan answers late last year I want
to know first of all kind of like the
question a lot of people are asking
which is how much of a ubisoft game is
this is this very very very familiar or
is it actually breaking interesting new
grant it does it's very familiar
definitely it's the Far Cry structure
you don't have to climb radio towers you
don't know it's a second question don't
have a race that a kind of a tedious
part of the games for three and four
especially but you do it's a it's the
Far Cry structure but of course you know
it's back in stone age twelve thousand
years ago it's 10,000 BC hmm they really
did I just say that right ten thousand
yeah 10,000 bc i mean i'm not gonna [ __ ]
jacked your guys so it is there's this
thing at the beginning the very
beginning it like counts back from 2418
but it's the Far Cry structure but
they're doing enough enough interesting
things that for the four hours last
slide oh yeah I was attacking people
Jesus so in FarCry 4 you could command
that tiger when you go to the shangri-la
like Jimmy sequences they've taken that
and made a hole like progression tree
out of you know the people have seen the
beastmaster abilities and you can you
contain new animals and they're pretty
much your co-op companions you can find
a bear you can ride them which we did we
just weren't allowed to show so that was
like tertiary stuffing far cry before
how much of this game involves actually
having to do like how much of the game
involves you just working with animals
very much working with and against so
it's almost like fighting out of humans
unless you're near a camp of the other
tribes it's almost entirely you versus
like tigers and jaguars and Panthers and
bears and uh oh oh my god nice nice I
you know your it's very very focused on
hunting and gathering the way you
upgrade your skills
new skin almost you have the central
village that you return to ok instead of
these you know like three and four and
two or just these outposts where you had
armories and you could get supplies and
rest and everything and get new missions
this is all mainly focused around your
village which you're upgrading and in
order to get new skills you have these
specialists these characters you're
recruiting out in the wilderness ok
saying hey I have a safe cave come back
here yeah a lone wanderer yeah but a
compass candy and everything I'm not
gonna eat you or not active what would
you lure them in with back then like it
wouldn't be candy looking food man
there's a dead bear haven't finished yet
look how hard it is to live back then
what type of specialist are these feels
like what demolitions yeah I / no 11 is
like communications and you can set up
like like satellite relays and stuff no
I'm kidding others there's a shaman who
he's the one that you want you I you
basically build up all these rugs yeah
I'm and I unlock the new skills he
covers the beastmaster tree okay so you
can get new tears of animals so you can
you contain like a wolf at first like
d-dog kind of thing great and then you
start off with the owl which like Scouts
post then you get a wolf and then you
get bears and jaguars but you also get
new attacks like you Scout with your owl
you can later on get an attack where he
just like dive-bombs someone and pecks
their face off right and drop grenades
as well yeah drop like be had a loop you
know like looking like poop explodes
it's very metal gear he's kind of you
can scout from far away and then send in
your animal attack and you know it's
kind of like oh and stealthily with a
bow so are they kind of like you're an
extension of your cuz like obviously
this is a game when I guns right so like
this Sammy and Suzie says head
definitely uses to play at without a
fire mar a firearm are there any like
first-person combat mechanics or is
there are like are the animals an
extension of you you're there very much
an extension of you point to certain
people and it'll tack them or you can
tell them to go somewhere taming them is
a big thing but they're also you know
kind of defense you have to heal them
but you it is very different in terms of
combat because you don't have a machine
gunner grenade launcher to fall back on
you have bow and arrow so they model on
PCs yeah until they just make it far cry
primal 20-26 yeah I don't know good year
yeah you get a club and okay years so
you can either stab with the spears
which is a very direct forward attack or
throw them which has almost always a one
l but you only have two of them at first
until you upgrade your capacity so it's
a very brutal combat for I've seen
you're really just smashing people's
heads with a club and then you know when
there's a lot of moving targets the bow
and arrows kind of harder to use and the
loop that you experience was that same
kind of thing like okay it's gonna be
like a story bit at the start then you
have your little village and then large
open world and you can kind of go off in
any direction you want yeah you can they
say it's comparable in size to four I
don't know that I could confirm that
from what I saw it's definitely just as
dense there's a lot of it still shows
animals in the map where you can hunt
wolves and where you can hunt Jaguars
but it's also you know you go back to
your village and get a mission from this
specialist that you've recruited and
they'll say go do this and that progress
the story because there are other tribes
that you're fighting there's like the
Odom which is are cannibals okay and
there's the azilla which are all like
they're called the flame walkers they
use fire like a lot the intro sequence
to how you meet that tribe is pretty
gross actually but it's a very the game
overall is really dark even for three
and four it's really just like kind of
brutal and grim and you know just every
that this whole tribe uses fire to fight
people if that gives you an indication
of like the brutality of like these
cutscenes you're seeing what is the the
structure of the village in terms of
like society and politics like are their
leaders that you have to sort of work
with or is that just sort of like
implied and it they don't really touch
on it no I guess there are people like
walking around and you can make your own
dwelling you're pretty much the leader
the trailer thakkar you're the leader of
the you're removing the one yeah you're
rebuilding the when jet tribe which used
to be this the one peaceful and like
they were a very not anymore Anton
science if he's such a thing existed
back now but they were trying to like
just gather knowledge and they weren't
too warlike but you're just rebuilding
that and then I there's not very much of
a political thing it's these specialists
are in huts it's upgrade the specialist
and unlock more Skills you just upgrade
these huts by hunting certain animal
skins I mean it sounds kind of like
you're going like in FarCry forward and
like going into a ruinous so until that
point a rev 0 worlds I Liam I don't just
people just call themselves Dave Hunt
which says I since the game is close to
early release only about a couple of
months more how does that does the game
feel rushed at all so does it feel like
a sort of a conversion mod for far cry 4
or does
it feel like its own thing because it's
it's doing a lot of different stuff so
it should feel different but does it it
feels know it feels done it feels like
its own thing it feels polished it's
like I said people who are expecting
another Far Cry will get that but from
the four hours I played I cannot speak
to the whole game I have not played more
than four hours and from the four hours
I played it is it feels like its own
different thing that is worth playing
for a little while but again it's those
games always a big complaint a lot
people have the second half is just more
of mortar safe yeah couldn't survive
without being called Far Cry primal like
what if it was just called primal um I
do you think the game is strong enough
to stand on its own without these sort
of ties to a thing that people love um
yeah I think it's it could stand on its
own but I obviously like having the Far
Cry gives you a glimpse into what you're
expecting is structurally um yeah I
don't know it had like I know a lot
people thought might be like a Blood
Dragon size thing at first yeah it's
like sixty dollars full-size game they
turned it around real quick i mean the
perception is sort of like hey where did
that come from it's already out yeah
totally i could yeah i could very well
see that i'm having say okay here's a
team that while for is being finished
you're gonna start from the same
framework and start working on this and
then we're gonna bring those people over
I don't know what the actual internal
things were but I could very much see
them as simultaneous things if not soon
after that started from the same
foundation it's kind of refreshing like
it's like the fallout 4 that was very
unique but like that was kind of cool
came out of nowhere yeah but they
haven't done it before we grow home that
was a game that you be obviously much
much much much smaller in terms of scale
and the doubles game is just a piano I'd
like literally they were like hey it's
at go play it and it seems like folks
are interested in this because it does
have those touchstones of of the older
for our experiences i guess like you
gotta wonder how much longer they can do
this before it starts becoming a little
bit wrote and for you did it you know
you why haven't you play for hours was
yeah 3 hours of the intro sequences and
like how they're teaching everything in
that a loaded open world and then they
jumped us to a point where we had a lot
more beasts on lot more abilities and
you meet the asilah tribe and you fight
them hard to say obviously in that sort
of situation did it feel were you
interested to play more to feel like I
had like legs was was that going in and
sort of double AB what he called those
Spears yeah I was the double spearing it
was
was that fun it get it get that one it
sold me enough to be interested than I
was before I played it which is which
says something but again I'm kind of
worried that it won't last past like
five six hours when I'm actually in the
open world and realized that I could be
doing this with machine guns all right
cuz I don't know I guess time will tell
yeah fine last question Saxton at Hotch
Ibaka on twitter asks how much caveman
junk is in it there's kind of see some
dong oh okay Mitchell ya say mr. go
where / I be better Jones I didn't see
any in see any there's no no one was
hanging for it a ton yeah for today
there's nothing you got myself out there
ya know I didn't see any it's a shame
DLC again mods PC a full review will
have specific yeah Karen of harmony dong
spa com we got you covered Mike my
hearty thank you so much for talking to
us about Far Cry primal appreciate your
time and let us know what you think of
Far Cry primal a slightly furred is it a
game and that you looking forward to
this year is are you final duel for
games there's this one piquing your
interest on its own let us know in the
comments hello do down there then there
then there